perched on the surface of a survivor we
survey the solar system 16 million years
have passed since solid matter first
froze in the solar nebula only 1.3
percent of Earth's history
those first tiny particles of matter
coalescing initially into dust
then mountain sized planetesimals and
finally dozens of planetary embryos
doomed for a fight to the death now
after an explosive race for mass and
dominance only a handful of proto
planets remain the surface of our proto
planet is a blasted and blazing
wasteland coated by dead oceans of magma
fueled by the primal Inferno of atomic
decay sustained for a time by the
bruising reign of planetesimals but
these are mostly gone now too absorbed
by hungry worlds or else ejected into
the depths of the solar system and
picked off by the leviathans
lurking there the table scraps of this
primal feast fall regularly on to our
proto planet one of its most successful
feeders on the surface of fractured
heaps of fused and jagged debris blasted
apart by the incessant bombardment a
hazy atmosphere of carbon dioxide
blankets the broken landscape moisture
wets the dust somewhere on the surface
they may even be a new kind of ocean
forming we may even imagine that someday
this scrappy champion will sprout
another newcomer life
or we would be wrong our proto planet is
not earth its name is Thea despite an
impressive start Thea is not destined to
win this planetary competition for
another combatant lurks in its orbit
over the horizon another proto planet
Corrine's interview Thayer's a larger
cousin the earth having experienced its
own similar and short history this young
world is just moments away from its
final act of formation the burning
sphere swells until it is eaten the sky
at last with a deafening Rumble the two
survivors crush into one another
towering waves of material erupt and
cascade into roiling chaos chunks of
planet splash into orbit as the earth
devours its last meal the ruptured
planet consumes Thea hole as the energy
of the impact melt solid rock into
oceans of liquid magma yet again in the
sky the blazing chaos gradually quiets
and the process of accretion begins this
disk of debris will soon form the
Earth's eternal companion the moon this
is Thea's gravestone
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
after nearby supernova sent shockwaves
through our featureless cloud of gas and
dust after that cloud began to collapse
spinning ever faster as it shrank
spreading outwards as its spun after the
Sun kindled into being at the center of
that shrinking spinning spreading cloud
the first two fragments of dust at the
center of our story crash into each
other and stick together
welcome to earth our world begins as a
scattering of dust particles so small
gravity cannot even hold them together
static electricity instead sticking each
piece to another the disc around the Sun
is transforming from gas into dust the
clouds freezing into silicate crystals
and complexes of calcium and aluminium
magnesium and iron as they grow they
experience drag for the first time the
gas they were once part of now sapping
their energy the largest of these nebula
snowflakes cascade from the outskirts
collecting at the disks central plane as
our nascent earth drifts towards the Sun
it is also falling in on itself
the more the snowflakes grow the more
energy is sapped by the passing nebula
earth faces its most dangerous challenge
if it does not grow quickly it will be
captured by the gravity of the Sun and
plummet into the furnace worse as our
clump of dust expands to the size of a
pebble the electrostatic forces feeding
it cease to be effective yet neither can
gravity bring new material to an object
so small pebbles drift past each other
unaffected a fortunate few collide only
to ricochet and drift apart or worse
fragment and disperse
growth has stalled
[Music]
[Music]
in the inner disk vast throngs of
meteors stream towards the Sun many are
as large as a metre across and still
struggling to grow most will not survive
but the earth is truly lucky it is
located in a region of concentrated
nebula that will collapse mutually
attracted by its cumulative mass the
earth expands rapidly past the danger
zone now it can set its own traps for
its doomed cousins siphoning off mass
bound for the Sun while the meteors
plunge inward the gas billows away
radiation from the juveniles Sun pushes
the vapors outward the hydrogen and
helium leave the earth behind carbon
leaves water leaves even potassium and
sulfur leave carried away by solar winds
the earth will not see these elements
again for millions of years as the earth
grows into a planetesimal many
kilometers in diameter it begins to melt
the closest material has always been
scorched by the Sun but this heat
doesn't originate from the heart of the
nebula but from the matter of the nebula
itself
radioactive decay the raw fire of nuclei
tortured into unstable monstrosities now
concentrated on the proto-earth they are
self-immolating on mass aluminium 26 a
demon born alongside the nebula has a
half-life of only seven hundred and
thirty thousand years the energy of its
destruction melts the interior of the
earth separating the heavy metallic iron
from the lighter elements it sinks to
the center of the planetesimals gloms
together for the first time Earth has a
core
but the earth is not alone while a
tremendous volume of material is plunged
into the Sun a multitude of other
planetesimals Corrine through its
neighborhood and more are forming all
the time
these bodies now commence a battle for
survival and for a place in the solar
system mostly molten mountains of
material roamed the disk for their prey
these gladiators destroy and a lesser
body drawn in by their gravitational
pull when two equally matched combatants
cross paths a fling each other wildly
into new orbits at first chaos rules
over the arena with such spoils readily
available the largest planetesimals grow
exponentially
but once the frontrunners of this battle
royale have established themselves a
tense truce settles in each combatant
carves out a zone of influence an
uncontested orbit where it can
systematically finish off every other
opponent the earth emerges is one of
these champions settling down to a comfy
snack but in this solar system there is
always a bigger fish
Jupiter advances from the outer regions
formed by the frozen volatiles once
ejected from the inner disk the
primordial jupiter edges ever closer
planetesimals ensnared by the behemoth
share two fates they are devoured by
this icy tighten or fatally flung from
the solar system into oblivion and with
each doomed body launched outwards
jupiter lurches inwards within reach of
more victims jupiter rampages through a
hapless crowd of fleeing and flying
planetesimals ever closer to the
unformed vulnerable earth at just
one-and-a-half times the distance from
the earth to the Sun Jupiter's attention
is snatched by another colossal beast
Saturn locked in gravitational combat
these two monsters heave and shove each
other
dragging themselves ultimately back into
the depths of the outer disk left behind
is a depopulated wasteland the only
planet that will form in this vast
region is the comparatively tiny Mars
staffed of material Mars is mostly
complete after the first few million
years safe in the inner disk the future
planets of Mercury and Venus are forming
as his earth perched on the edge of
no-man's land
the luckiest survivor only a couple of
million years have passed since the
creation of the solar nebula and much
has changed the gas has drifted away the
nuclear Inferno has calmed Jupiter has
come and gone already most of the mass
in the inner disk is concentrated in
dozens of planetary embryos one to ten
percent of the mass of the modern earth
among them are the adolescent Mercury
Venus Mars Earth and Theia as well as
many other contenders it will take many
tens of millions more years to decide
the ultimate winners
[Music]
while Jupiter lays waste to the edge of
the inner disk the Sun wreaks havoc near
its center 50 kilometres from the Sun
her children whip around at incredible
speeds collisions here are catastrophic
when proto planets clash it is rarely
clean instead they rip into each other
spraying their insides across the void
and part again circling then clash again
on the next orbit and the next finally
the two bodies will collapse into each
other when proto mercury encounters
another embryo they impact with such
ferocity their Mantle's vaporize Jets of
gaseous planets spout away from the
roiling course leaving mercury much
reduced in mass and enriched in iron
with so many gladiators and such erratic
sparring the ultimate Victor's will be
chosen by chance as this happens
glimpses of future earth appear the
firestorm of radioactivity has died away
but the oceans of magma it created still
burble beneath the surface as the oceans
slowly solidify the materials of the
earth organized themselves iron sinks to
the core
along with nickel and other heavy
elements that bond with iron crystals
precipitate in the swirling molten
matter most shower onto the core and
amass Indians thousands of kilometers
thick the lightest elements and the most
unreactive seep upwards and outwards and
freeze near the surface the earth forms
layers
asteroids explode through the whisper
thin atmosphere and blast the solid
surface into dust
it accumulates into drifts until the
direct impact fuses the matter into
solid stone once again great vents
breached the surface and molten mantle
leaks through seas of magma puddle and
solidified but this cohesion is
short-lived
Armageddon returns to earth each time it
devours a defeated foe surface is
vaporized Mantle's sloshed and a new
surface congeals earth starts again
water and the other volatiles reappear
after tens of millions of years absent
asteroids planetesimals possibly even
ice rains down upon our proto planet now
with something to cling to the carbon
ice and gases that were driven away by
the heat of the Sun have begun to
repopulate the Earth's surface after 16
million years of halting growth and
abortive evolution the earth has nearly
reached its final mass only one more
collision one more victim separates
Earth from the end of its origin story
and the beginning of its history
there's orbit intersects that of Earth
[Music]
by their combined gravity they turn
towards each other and lean into the
below the impact is devastating crushed
between the two planets solid rock
atomizes shockwaves liquefy the mantle
fragments of the earth buried thousands
of kilometers deep are ejected into
space the planet staggers on its axis as
it crumples back into a sphere oceans of
Hellfire tumble onto the surface
superheated gas and droplets of magma
suffocate the earth the extremities of
this lunar disk rapidly coalesce into a
hellish sphere the dwarfs even the Sun
[Music]
over the next 150 years the cloud of
dust billows outward little moonlets
coagulate and spin off to join the moon
it is a replica of the Earth's formation
we played in miniature this is the last
altercation Earth has with another proto
planet asteroid
and planetesimals continued falling to
earth and the moon for hundreds of
millions more years but another impact
of this magnitude would have left scars
on the moon if not obliterated entirely
Thayer's destruction is unique only in
that it came last many other upstarts
met similar fates at the hands of the
earth it's probable that several
different moons graced the sky around
our planet before our moon formed it is
a sign of the changing times that this
companion sticks around the earth is
done growing but it is far from complete
our planet is not a blue marble but red
and black and broken after 60 million
years Earth has only begun its journey a
journey that will change it from the
edge of the atmosphere to it's very core
[Music]
[Music]